what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we just saw Shazam Fury of
the Gods
um yeah we were gonna shoot this at the
theater but uh they were closing up shop
and because it is pouring rain right now
but Greg and John we are committed to
doing this standing and outside like a
normal just watched video so we're in
the backyard
standing in the in the wet risking this
mic being destroyed because we love you
guys that much first things first leave
a like for our resilience to this format
for a just watched we saw the movie 20
minutes ago and we're gonna rock these
thoughts like nobody's business today
also um I wanted to give a quick mention
koi John and I we are going to be having
a panel at WonderCon Sunday March 26th
11 o'clock A.M if you're going to
WonderCon please come attend if you were
on the fence about going I don't know if
I want to go but now I do want to go and
then come please come say hi we'd love
to have you anyway let's talk about
Shazam Fury of the god plot of the movie
John spitball something quick hey this
is Emily they're fighting crimes around
Philly but ooh they're all experiencing
personal issues they want to go off in
their own directions but then ooh these
ancient Greek Daughters of Atlas they're
coming to Earth because they got a score
to settle they want to find the staff
and and restore the greatness of their
old land and and you know who's standing
in the way it's old Shazam and the team
and they Gotta Throw Down against them
and and Vanquish them and and all that
stuff I think that was cohesive I think
you got it yeah I think you did a pretty
good job well guys um here's the first
thing I'll tell you it's better than
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum me sure
yeah yeah that's uh that's that's the
particle ride yeah yeah but is it better
than the first Shazam I don't personally
think so what do you think no it
certainly is not without its charms but
the first movie Just breathes so much
better yeah I like this movie overall I
do have a pretty good amount of qualms
with the film though and so let's we
let's try to balance this review out a
tiny bit though okay uh let's start off
with the pros the pros are every Pro I
think kind of comes with a bit of a
caveat all right that's probably the
best way for me to put it right now
because the format it is really raining
today it is heavier the more we speak we
are doing this we're doing this all
right even like we could just be inside
but we're stupid let's keep it going oh
do you love us now
it's a sequel so you know they go you
want to go like twice as big twice as
epic for something that wasn't that epic
to begin with and that was part of it
something that was like that was part of
the charm of the first one and I will
say that like I think there's some
pretty great action scenes in here one
thing that I really like um that they
did differently this time was they truly
enhanced the Fantastical Wizarding side
The Wizarding World if you will to see
the Gods in mythology yeah yeah as much
as I think the second trailer does show
you a little too much honestly uh
because the movie was very predictable
and the second trailer doesn't help with
that at all they do have a lot of things
in here they still don't show in the
trailer though there's a lot of
different creatures character types that
I would say was really well done and
surprising and you know David F Sandberg
who has a pretty big horror background
he does bring some of that charm
periodically more ingrained in the first
movie with the seven deadly sins I would
have to agree with you there the casting
is an interesting thing because like I
said there's a caveat with almost every
part but the cast overall yeah overall
everybody shows us understand it does a
fine job my standout
uh would have to be mine is Helen Mirren
Joshua he's having a blast I'm kind of
back and forth with what they doing this
Helen Mirren I was the most pleasant
surprise like she really brings the
level of Shakespearean you know
classicism that you want and Greek
mythological bombast and pump that you
want we're gonna catch a cold we are but
yeah the cast overall everybody shows up
everybody is is fun and pleasant and and
you know has a good note but it's not
always serving them as a whole or as an
ensemble necessarily the movie in
general in an attempt to balance this
review we're saving some of the
criticisms for a little bit later but
yeah there's there's everybody does fine
work I think everybody showed up I don't
think anyone half-assed this and then
like there's a lot of humor a lot of
humor a lot of humor and then some of
it's pretty funny there's some pretty
big laugh out loud moments that I that I
had in this film other Pros Sean you
know the the action is pretty uh so I
said that in the world it's fun it's fun
yeah yeah I know I mean overall it's fun
like it is fun it's fun and enjoyable
and if you like the first shazam movie
especially it certainly has a lot of the
things you enjoyed and the people and
the Dynamics and the imagination and
everything they attempt at least I think
is a worthy and an interesting idea
whether or not they hit the nail on
those heads is a different story yeah
because now they're going to the cons
which would be like from mid to cons is
kind of where I would sort of brief it
at because here's what I'll say a lot of
you guys might know that on my rewatch
of Thor love and thunder I I
significantly went down for me and what
I said with Thor love and thunder was I
really felt like there was an overload
of jokes especially in the first half
and it get it clicks better in the
second half of the movie my opinion of
my rewatch of Thor love and thunder is
my opinion of my first watch of Shazam
area of the Gods I was like there's a
lot lot of jokes in this movie and it's
often at the times of undercutting
tension because the first one's funny
like that's the thing that a lot of
people have with it same thing I might
say with Thor Ragnarok that's a funny
movie uh and this one though it really
felt like there's a lot of very overt
kind of sketch comedy humor and a lot of
the characters are given jokes including
the wizard and yes which is a jokier
movie it's not just a movie with a lot
of humor and it got to the point where I
was like you got real in these jokes man
yeah a lot of jokes happen and it just
doesn't stop and it really doesn't stop
until like the last 20 minutes of the
movie and it creates an odd contrast
because you have such a greater
abundance of jokes but then you also
have like even more world-rending you
know Universe shattering Stakes yes and
so that can make uh some of the big
stuff feel small and some of the small
stuff feel like it's just lost in the
sea of chaos yeah yeah also oh one thing
another Pro I I you know I like Helen
mirrenal I thought she brought a lot to
the role even though the character all
the characters I think are pretty much
underwritten except for a couple
there's not enough time the film's over
stuff there's a lot of there's a lot of
characters in here and uh there's a lot
of different plow and a lot of the plots
lines that they set up kind of just get
dropped a lot of arcs that they said
kind of get dropped but one character I
thought uh they introduced a bunch of
powers with her they revealed a
Comic-Con who her character really is so
I feel like I can say it Rachel
Ziegler's character yeah and her her
character had some really awesome powers
in this film like that what they did
visually with hers was great that being
said this movie's budget I felt for the
visual effects was really reserved for
the last 20 minutes of this film because
a lot of the visual effects they're
really going big here but at times it
reminded me of Justice League you guys
remember what Justice League was like
there was a lot of times where the
visual effects were reminding me of that
like the look and the vibe and the fact
that it just didn't have enough money or
time to really do it it really just
didn't support a lot of the they go so
much bigger in this film that at times
the visual effects is we weakness was
kind of distracting to me whereas in the
first movie I was like yeah it's not
really about the big stuff here so you
know whatever we can forgive that yeah I
think the quantumania comparison does
hold here because this is clearly a
budgeting you know step up from the
previous movie as was quantumania and I
think it's not quite ready to balance
the weight of all that extra bombast no
no not really yeah and some of the VFX
some look great and some don't so much
the shazamilee I mean if you guys
remember the first movie without being
so cool if you guys remember the first
movie with this is Emily they got a
bunch of like semi-celebrity people to
be the the adult Shazam people right and
here you get they get a lot more screen
time as you would expect when you see
the trailers that being said I really
felt like I didn't get to know any of
them better because they have a rather
complicated lore here where they were
like we got to spread out the exposition
here which they do they spread out the
exposition but they're kind of just
given Exposition they do a little bit
with Pedro was like the DJ Katrina
character they do some interesting stuff
with Freddy in the beginning like Adam
Brody gets some interesting stuff to do
where he's struggling with his ego and I
think there's a character Arc there
because it really seems like they're
setting up a character Arc there and
hold on to the theme I think it's there
but it kind of gets lost in in the
jumble of all the chaos that's going on
in this film because there's a lot of
family in general both in kid form and
in adult form while they certainly
appear on screen often feel like they
were just here for a second and now
they're gone again like Zach Levi still
leads a lot of the action and a lot of
the main parts of the story but the
thing
I which I really feel is for love and
thunder jokey like too much is they like
made him exceptionally Dumber this time
around I was like what happened here why
is he so much Dumber at the personality
gap between regular Billy Batson and
Shazam Billy Batson is pretty wide as
the Asher Angel and Zach Levi yeah yeah
it's like the youngest sister is the one
who matches her character the most
between Mexico yeah Darla and a bit I'll
give uh Jorge a bit of that with between
DJ katrona and the younger actor like
because he has that sort of sulky thing
but you know the rest of them the
congruity just isn't as on point as you
would hope it would be yeah yeah I feel
like this movie really clicks together
in like the last half hour of the film
uh where there's like it's got a good
balance of humor and intensity and
there's some emotional half there's one
scene where I think I looked over and I
saw John tearing up a little bit was
that happening that happened yeah I saw
John it was a sign that it was working
for someone the first shazam movie was
like it's too like DC was known for
being darker and and this one is
like doing all the thing it's learning
all these good things that Marvel's
doing that's what the first shazam movie
did and this movie did all the bad
things that Marvel's been doing and they
felt like they tried to make Black Adam
a Marvel movie this who read it to me
it's cut from a similar cloth but at the
same time with like the Thor love and
thunder was like yeah it was really
I think this is better than Thor love
and thunder it's a more smooth
experience and I will give Dave David F
Sandberg credit because for a movie that
I feel like probably was compacted and
had a lot of stuff it needed to jam in
like it could be a lot more disarrayed
you know like he's good at pulling these
things together so Props for that but
you can tell kind of like Justice League
sure
it's way better than Josh way better
than John way better than the job I put
it in the same way of like this could
have been messenger yeah it's not as
much of a letdown as I imagine a lot of
people experience with like a Thor love
and thunder because you know there isn't
that quite level of like Stakes to
satisfy but coming off a pretty Pleasant
hit with the first movie it just doesn't
quite leave you as inspired and feeling
as fresh as that movie did yeah that
first movie has a real like personal
simple intimate touch to it and and a
lot of that really does get lost in this
film with with trying to go bigger but
but I I appreciated the the small doses
when we did get those moments with the
family with the parents uh even though I
feel like there are character Arc
moments that certainly got dropped or
like they have this whole thing in the
beginning of the movie about shazamly is
not really uh working as a unit right
now guys all of us are not of us but it
doesn't really uh go anywhere with that
one it's just the main Adventure just
kind of takes control of the whole plot
yeah kind of falls into the back seat
and then out the door Lucy Liu is kind
of really exceptionally one note in this
film even though the dragon's really
cool she's got good presence but she's
just here to be angry and then Rachel
zegler's is is so Charming yeah and is
also a God I guess but mostly she's just
here to be super Charming they made the
wizard a goofball
um he's funny in this movie yeah it's
really funny yeah he's pretty this movie
dips into silliness and weirdness in a
more overt way than the previous one uh
two mixed results but I mean I'm happy
they decided to try it exactly why
despite being much Dumber he's still
very very Charming I'll say that and
Jack Dylan Crazer uh he's resorted a lot
to being very very loud in this movie
he's just very loud but he also has some
of the best moments at the same time
yeah MVP Freeman anyway yeah uh I was a
seven out of this six point eight out of
10. give it a 6.8 I would say 68 yeah
three point seven Nine Stars 3.82 some
something like that something like that
it's three plus five six just enjoyable
enough for me to give it a fresh rating
yeah I feel Pleasant at the moment
anyway you guys catch us at one Recon we
gotta go shoot Mandalorian in a half
hour now but we wanted to make sure we
did her just watched thank you so much
for being here leave your thoughts down
below for Shazam for you're the gods
there's two post credit scenes one of
them is really funny as usual and uh the
other ones
like okay we didn't need to swing swing
for the fences and maybe they'll give
you a green light who knows alrighty
guys we'll we'll see you later thanks
for being here reject Nation Shazam
foreign